the Trump administration is outlining
the terms of a proposed new nuclear deal
with Iran America's top diplomat is
threatening what he calls these
strongest sanctions in history if Iran
does not comply Iran is predictably
dismissive correspondent Richardson has
specifics from the State Department
tonight
the United States will implement an
aggressive campaign to economically
isolate and punish Iran these will
indeed end up being the strongest
sanctions in history when we are
completely borrowing a tactic and even a
name from the administration's North
Korea policy Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo promises an historic pressure
campaign against Iran State Department
officials say they will continue working
with allies to create a global coalition
to counter Iran secretary Pompeo also
warned companies from allied countries
conducting business with Iran that the
United States would penalize them if
they continued working with Iran all
part of what the administration says is
a robust strategy to address Iran's
behavior
beyond nuclear activity we will track
down Iranian operatives and there has
Belov proxies proxies operating around
the world and we will crush them Iran
will never again have carte blanche to
dominate the Middle East
Pompeyo lifted a dozen US demands among
them Iran must abandon its nuclear work
in perpetuity provide international
inspectors unqualified access halt its
ballistic missile program release
detained Americans and end support for
Middle East militant groups in exchange
the secretary says the US would lift
sanctions and welcome Iran's return to
the global economy in response iran's
Foreign Minister tweeted quote US
diplomacy sham is merely a regression to
old habits imprisoned by delusions and
failed policies dictated by corrupt
special interest it repeats the same
wrong choices and will thus reap the
same ill rewards British Foreign
Secretary Boris Johnson speaking just
ahead of secretary Pompeo says a larger
agreement addressing all of Iran's
aggressive behavior won't be very easy
to achieve in a reasonable time Brett
Bridget's in that the State Department
rich thank you